What's up guys?
Check it out, we finally got a fairly nice day of good weather.
So for this video, we're back outside.
Now for the last couple of months my comment section has been blowing up with people asking me to do something with fidget spinners.
Make my own fidget spinners, modify fidget spinners.
So I've been gearing up to do that however,
On yesterday's video the most popular comment was from Jo Deon who said: "Can you please not do anything fidget spinner.
I find they are overdone, and they would ruin  you.
And apparently this has become the most popular comment so i'm switching strategies.
in this video rather than making fidget spinners, I'll be destroying them
Now, a couple of months ago when I realized fidget spinners were a thing, I reached out to a few different companies
to get some prototype samples and brand them "king of random" style.
the problem is, not all fidget spinners are created equal and I went trough bucket-loads of samples trying to find some that I like.
and after months of going back a forward these are the only two that I settled on because they are both made of metal and I like the way they look.
I also noticed the spinners that only have two sides seem to wobble...
when you turn them back and forward, which is no good
and a lot of spinners seem to have problems with their bearings, they just dont work the way they should.
So I finally have a product here that I'm proud of and ready to sell but, I feel like I'm a little late to the game.
However, I will put a link down in the description if you want to get the "king of random" brand fidget spinners.
Not sure how long they will be here, because the purpose of this video is really to take all the extra samples, fire up the metal foundry
and see what happens when we melt them all together.
Now for this experiment, I'm going back to this backyard metal foundry we made with the kale wool, and I have various sized crucibles here.
and uhh, I don't think were going to need this huge one, so I'm just going to use this middle sized one here.
do you remember how this worked? we just stick a couple of gas jets from the sides, fire it up, let it get nice and hot
and then we will start adding our fidgets in one-by-one
YEAHH!
*Exclamation sounds*
That is awesome
Now looking at these spinners, most of them seem to be made of aluminium, some seem to be made of brass,
but in either case im going to be using this "roach away" as a flux.
It's just 100% boric acid, and thats going to help the metal melt down a little quicker, and keep it a little bit cleaner.
Alright, our foundry is heated up and is ready for melting, I think im going to start the melting off with this spinner here,
I call this my ninja spinner because it looks like a little throwing star.
This thing is made of aluminum, you can see that because I shaved down the side here, and I think the whole thing is aluminum
except for the steel bearings on the inside
lets go ahead and toss it in!
Whoo! Thats toasty!
Here we go!
That's gotta be getting pretty toasty!
That's holding up pretty good so far.
Look at the tip of the spinner here, you can see thats starting to melt!
ohhh wow
Im gonna give it a little stir
ohh its gone, look at that!
fidget spinner has just become a blob of molten metal!
so the first one has been taken down, here comes fidget spinner number two.
Here we go!
1!
oh yeah thats the money shot!
whoo doggie!
*Metal splashes*
ohh! Ouch!
oh my god! That just exploded all over my face!
I think the battery in those LED's just exploded and went all over my shirt, my skin and the camera!
Dude your lens! Check it out!
That right there is why we wear safety glasses.
Molten!
cool!
Yeah!
Roach Killer!
Check it out!
So update guys, our aluminum spinners are gone!
They're completely liquified.
So were moving up to brass!
Oh dude look at the colors!
What the crazy heck is going on?!
We've got like teal blue flames shooting out of the top here
Oh my gosh! and the metal is boiling!
It's bubbling, its boiling, it looks absolutely insane!
We've got to take this lid off and have a look!
Alright check this out
woaah!
wow!
Im pretty sure that's the zinc burning off right now
Lets throw a little bit of our roach killer in there
to suppress the oxygen
Whew! There we go see
roach killer to the rescue!
and thats what the flux does, it prevents the oxygen from getting down there and burning off the zinc.
So who knew? Burn a brass fidget spinner and you get teal blue flames
and a bright yellow explosion.
Glad nobody got hurt!
we've got our trusty mini metal muffin tray and were gonna gear up for the pouring now
as soon as I can cool down these gloves!
smokin'!
alright
can't even see where the pour spout is on this thing
so I guess it doesn't matter
check out down there! Look at that crucible
You can see its still so hot the zinc is burning off
Toasty!
Clean crucible is a happy crucible.
Quick update guys, we made the pour, it was successful  and we ended up with 5 fidget spinner ingots!
Now were just going to let them cool down for a minute, then knock them out of the tray and then quench them in water.
and then set them on a shelf where we can use them for some future project.
They look perfect!
Alright, let's flip this over
and give it a little bang on the ground,
Ugh! Thats what I was afraid of!
They are actually so hot they are melding with the steel in the muffin tray,
which means they are going to be really difficult to take out.
...and we did it.
Woah! You can see some of the crystal structure left on the inside! That looks really cool!
So we successfully did it guys! We took all of our rejected samples and melted them down together and this is the alloy we created.
It's some kind of aluminum brass alloy, I'm not sure what ratios, but it does look very brittle, so much to the stuff that we tried in the previous experiment
Now what I'm actually going to end up doing with these, I have no idea.
They will probably just sit on the shelf until I can think of some purpose for them in a future experiment
but apparently that's what happens when you melt down together a bunch of metal fidgets
and of course if you still want to jump on the craze and get yourself a metal fidget,
I put a link down in the description to these "King of Random" brand
These ones are metal and they spin really, really nicely and from all the samples that I tested,
these are the only ones that I really like.
and they come with these cool little zip-together cases, which I think are very neat and have never seen before.
So if you want one of these bad boys, just click the link in the description,
[and] that will take you to where you can find one of these metal fidget ninjas or the classic version as well,
as long as they are still available.
as for these, well I've got 4 boys of my own so I think im just going to pass these on
and see what kind of havoc they cause at school.
and of course a big shoutout to Jo Deon for leaving a comment getting the popular vote.
Go ahead and check your YouTube inbox Jo, ill send you 25 bucks!
Well thats it for this experiment guys, you now know what happens when you throw metal fidget spinners into a backyard metal foundry
Thanks for joining me in this video, and I'll be looking for you in the next one!
Talk to you then!
3... 2.... 1... Oh! I missed!
We've invented a new element.... "Randinium"
[Outro with background music]